my days as a shy young woman had long
since been left by hmm de pon mi Miyagi
Conrad mm say grinder makan Patel dem
bus microphone with a dick Oh pitiful
ahem I'm saber and which is hit rate
some fan fiction has been made up about
us yeah Bob our characters nothing and
also weak always brave a kiss
apparently they put her in say these
days no in a weird way just I don't
think but let's not think about there's
more trousers on so fight yes I appeared
friends in relax and enjoy the
whispering I've been a noise abatement
officer for some time now this means our
money's job is to stop noise then there
wasn't any doubt in my mind that this
power station was about to shut down
yeah in my younger more fun for years
this kind of vacation would have
terrified the living daylights
no any more than my days as a shy young
woman had long since been left behind
following a few sharp knocks the chain
de sounds came to the pop though and a
funny looking man resembling something
like a shriveled olive unset though he
had strands of what must have been heavy
greasy or excessively child by pepper
confers gap and jzuk I browse that
concludes my prepared is vulnerable and
Apache a strip affair
just above a pair of historic lips okay
nice man good afternoon sir I managed to
announce with a straight face am I
correct in thinking this is the
residence of corrupt mm hey is your man
MC even say is your man this MC grinder
but I'm MC fools I'm genius welcome to
croats FM he replied with a few
questionable actions I'm afraid we've
received a handful of complaints I'm
going to have to ask you to let me step
inside slightly defensively already plum
[Applause]
and ribs open to various poor anamensis
mouth like an unfit ohina hmm white bass
case a fire he stepped back and justice
for me - Enzo mo casa su casa by the
time my she clicked and against the
cheap vinyl flooring I was suddenly in
the presence of an impossibly masterly
for billeted man with fires as
endearingly gentle as they were intense
this big fella was wearing a bell pager
that would usually did nothing for a
fair skinned man but it works trust me
however is somehow made the glowing red
tinge of stubble Moses chiseled jawline
tiny jaw like a delicately inflated
balloon
the confidence I usually felt was
replaced with a wave of giddy stomach
twisting bar flies as I found my case
lingering on the centimeter of expose
doors no means to escape the restraints
of his jobs it
I followed the men's steps into the dark
smoke-filled Mount Airy with a flaw and
was the greasy shriveled man straighten
floral piece of paper a found on the
floor mishima bleah the ignored council
notice from the second the stallion in
the yellow cap from his mouth
I found myself imagining how slips would
feel whispering sweet nothings in way
mr. the character not me Rhonda was
given his soul to this place to get it
walk on the read anymore thank you -
given his soul to this place to get it
what it isn't that general main he began
I tried to listen power found myself
entranced by the way his lips bothered
directly as he spoke delicately they
exactly baking away for the tip of his
tongue to swipe against its lower lip
every so often just as I was starting to
fall into a trance the way oh I am so
hungry just as I was starting to thought
into it neurons pathway he was fairly
defending his friend the crazy surfer
man interrupted again
he broke into some kind of rap replica
in the same stretch and actions from
earlier when I'm gonna might decide to
Reno with a lady of the Sun inside fer I
flicked my eyes but source demanded at
my interest and to my surprise you study
right back at me my dear cheat against
the skin inside my mouth in an effort to
prevent me I could feel beginning to
spread across my cheeks but the cheeky
grin that spread across is perfectly
symmetrical face time across a
definitely toast his grumpy
confirm that my blush hadn't gone very
specific I'll chain my head the turn my
head to see if it is the effect it was
having on me but just at that moment his
phone started to ring sickening of a
circle break Egypt was just busy with
this lovely idea bestow it is screen in
my direction
no no am i bad was gonna throw the man
on the other side of the call really was
the kind of sculpted Adonis he just
wanted to crap yes and you want him to
throw you against him there is bed pull
or floor surface he was a younger man
clean-shaven sex broad are the recently
direct
tower block and was almost majestic as
he trusted his head France and nodded
absently towards me he looked right
through me almost as though I didn't
even exist but there was something about
his hard to get her dude they already
had me weak at the knees
I took my hand away from his contact
with the man besides me and put it to
all around of this strand of hair if
this man was corrupt affair
then maybe they did deserve lot more
jobs and they have it a weird whispering
story now wipe yourself down you filthy
animals yeah night-night he dare you
bastards he found he's in a bit
you